Mm,
I'm happy to John with you today in road
go down in history as the greatest
demonstration for freedom in the history
of our nation,
Martin Luther King's I have a dream
speech is arguably the most important
and most well known speech of the 20th
century.
It's 1,667
words in 17 minutes long,
absolutely riddled with big difficult
terms and full of rhetorical devices
that are intentional and practiced.
The speech is everyone knows was
delivered at the march on Washington in
1963 and voiced the economic,
political and moral message of civil
rights to a quarter million people in
front of the Lincoln memorial onto those
people and the billions who have seen or
heard it since king's words in printed
an image of what black Americans were
fighting for and why fully 100 years
after Abraham Lincoln freed the slaves
with the emancipation proclamation
five years ago,
a great American in whose symbolic
shadow we stand today signed the
emancipation proclamation.
The very first line of the speech is
already doing so much.
The first four words are an illusion to
Lincoln's Gettysburg address and
instantly recognizable piece of American
rhetoric that in one fell swoop,
links America's founding,
which Lincoln spoke of,
and the civil war when he spoke with the
fight for civil rights throughout the
speech.
King takes great pains to make links
like this.
It's important for him to frame civil
rights as a chapter in the larger
American mythology so that those who
identify with that mythology might
incorporate this struggle into that
story
on a,
on a bill of rights,
of life,
liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness,
but there's even more to see in this
first line.
One of the things that makes king's
words so memorable is their musicality.
Here he uses a literation,
five words starting with the letter s
that draw you along the sentence like a
tune that's catchy.
Alliteration helps a phrase stick in the
mind and king returns to it again and
again.
In this speech,
dark and desolate.
It's sweltering,
some out of the Negroes,
legitimate discontent,
the marvelous new militancy,
trials and tribulations,
dignity and discipline.
In a sense,
we've come to our nation's capital to
cash a check.
This isn't the only rhythmically aware
or musical feature of I have a dream.
There's another rhetorical device called
Anaphora,
which can use is even more than
alliteration and Africa is the
repetition of a word or phrase at the
beginning of success of sentences,
something that in writing would be
redundant,
but in speech is an effective tool for
emphasis and I have a dream.
Martin Luther King uses an Afro as an
emphasizing tool,
but also as an organizing device.
Listen to how phrases sketch the larger
ideas of the speech.
Almost like an outline,
but 100 years,
100 years,
100 years later,
we refused.
We refused to believe.
Now is the time.
Now is the power.
We can never be satisfied.
We cannot be satisfied.
I have a dream.
Freedom.
Freedom,
freedom,
freedom ring.
Let Freedom Ring.
The speech goes from the past to the
present to the future of civil rights,
and it's threaded with a refusal to
settle for anything other than the ideal
of freedom and equality.
I think this is a key to martin luther
king's rhetorical genius,
drawing from his Gospel roots.
He not only uses alliteration and
Anaphora even illusion for dramatic
effect,
but also to help the audience grasp of
the structure and remember the nuance of
his message.
King knows that for example,
you may not know this line from
Shakespeare
that was the winter of our discontent,
made glorious suburb by this sun appeal,
but the phrase will ring familiar,
sweltering,
some out of the Negroes,
legitimate discontent will not pass
until that is an invigorating autumn of
freedom and equality king shifts the
seasons,
of course,
because for those who live in the
American south,
autumn is more relieving than summer.
Know your audience and sticking with
this paragraph for just a moment,
notice that this sentence of
shakespearian poetry is couched in a
point about urgency and not settling and
the king isn't all flowery language.
He draws that image of paradise.
Then follows it with a sentence that
contains three easy to understand
cliches,
oh,
so that the Negro needed to blow off
steam and will now be content,
will have a rude awakening if the nation
returns to business as usual.
This mixing of plain and slash or neat
language is I think a microcosm of what
occurs in the entire speech after
alluding to the Gettysburg address.
In the declaration of Independence King
Compares the promises of those documents
to a bad check.
I'll check which has come back marked
insufficient funds.
You're invoking the plane realities of
police brutality for whites only,
signs and voter suppression.
He paraphrases
Bible.
We will not be satisfied until justice
rolls down like waters and righteousness
like a mighty stream.
The first half of the speech describes
in large part the issue at hand what is
to be done and demanded what is to be
avoided,
and he tells those who have suffered to
hold fast and believe while the final
part,
which was famously improvised by King on
the spot,
rises into the heights of dreams
I have shall be exalted.
Every hill and mountain shall be made
low.
The rough places will be made.
Wayne and the crooked places will be
made straight and the Lord shall be
revealed and all smashed shall see it
together.
In my video analyzing Donald Trump's
speech,
I talked about how he was able to
connect with people by using simple
language.
It's a good general rule for public
speaking.
When you're addressing a large diverse
audience,
the most important part of rhetoric is
being understood.
Trump does this by keeping his words
basic and emotional and it works,
but I think Martin Luther King offers a
counterexample of public speaking,
one that's more complex and layered in
language and structure,
but still just as easily understandable
as anything that current politicians or
speaker say and I have a dream.
The simple language contextualizes and
grounds the poetic and the poetic,
elevates and animates the simple.
That's why it echoes across time and
will echo for decades and ages to come
something vital and alive.
We won't be able to feed children,
black men and white men,
Jews and gentiles,
Protestants and Catholics will be able
to join hands and sing.
In the words of the old Negro spiritual
free at last,
free at last.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching and thank you to the
great courses plus for sponsoring this
episode.
If you love learning for fun,
which I do have the great courses.
Plus is it subscription on demand video
learning service.
It's got 7,000
online lecture series from some Great
Ivy League and other professors.
Um,
something that really sort of meshes
with what I was just talking about as a
great course by John mcwhorter from
Columbia about the usage of the English
language,
the myths about it.
And it goes into some of these things
about oratory that I obviously am
totally fascinated by because I think
it's sort of organizes the world anyway.
If you go to the great courses
plus.com/nerd
writer,
you can get a 30 day free trial if you
use the offer code nerdwriter I think
it's 1499 after that.
It's a really cool service if you just
like to learn things,
which I do.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I will see all of you.
Not next Wednesday,
but I'll be in Boston for neurocognitive
Vitoria with the link and description
below.
If you're in Boston,
come say hi.